القبض على لصوص فيلا صلاح جوليا روبرت
تكسير قلب غوارديولا مكافحه الشغب
الايطاليه تنقل جماهير فرانكفورت هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
الرياضه فاهلا بكم
كشفت الداخليه المصريه عن ضبط مرتكبي
واقعه سرقه فيلا محمد صلاح نجم منتخب مصر
ونادي ليفربول الانجليزي باحدى التجمعات
السكنيه بالقاهره الجديده واعاده
المسروقات وبحسب بيان الداخليه فانه بعد
اجراء التحريات وجمع المعلومات ومن خلال
تتبع خطوط السير تمكنت الاجهزه الامنيه من
تحديد مرتكبي الواقعه وتبين انهم شخصين
احدهما سبق له العمل كفرد امن بالمجمع
السكني المشار اليه وان الواقعه ارتكبت
بتاريخ الثاني من مارس الجاري
حتى لو فزتوا بدوري ابطال اوروبا ثلاثه
مرات متتاليه سابقى فاشلا هذا ما قاله
الاسباني في المؤتمر الصحفي بعد فوز
تاريخه سباعيه نظيفه على لايبزيك في ثمن
النهائي دوري الابطال غوارديولا اوضح ان
السبب يعود الى ما فعلته النجمه الامريكيه
جوليا روبرتس التي يعتبرها مثلا اعلى له
وذلك حين زارت مدينه مانشستر في 2016
وزارت ملعب اولترافورد مع كلونايتد بدلا
من ملعب الاتحاد ملعب الغريب مانشستر سيتي
سيلاقي نابولية الايطاليا الليله فريق
فرانكفورت الالماني في دوري ابطال اوروبا
وبينما تستعين الجماهير عاده بشركات
السياحيه لتامين تنقلاتهم ومساكنهم تدخلت
قوات مكافحه الشغب الايطاليه لنقل اولتراس
فرانكفورت الذي وصل ايطاليا لدعم فريقها
السلطات في المدينه الجنوبيه استعادت بست
حافلات لنقل الجماهير البالغين عددها 400
مشجع الى الفندق
[موسيقى]